nearly a year into the pandemic
teenagers and children across the
country are facing a mental health
crisis
many are still dealing with the stresses
of virtual classes and social isolation
and for some this is also coupled with
trauma
food insecurity and a parent's job loss
or even the death of a loved one from
coven
meg oliver is outside an elementary
school in little falls new jersey with
more on the story meg good morning to
you i'm really glad you're talking about
this
gail good morning experts tell us
depression is on the rise among children
and teens
at the beginning of the year we spoke
with an 11-year-old boy dealing with
depression
now about six months later we met up
with him inside his school
to see how he's doing five days a week
sixth grader rocco testa leaves home
to attend school in person in little
falls new jersey
hi it's so nice to see you again
we first met rocco in late august when
he bravely
opened up about his mental health during
the pandemic
it was just me being angry at the world
and everything because
because of covid and stuff like most
children
rocco spent last spring inside learning
in front of a computer
isolation took a heavy toll but many of
his frustrations
faded after he returned in person this
fall
are you still mad at the world no
not really at all you feel happy yeah
i feel a lot happier in september it was
like
my kid was back rocco's mom
gina testa is a guidance counselor in a
nearby district where school is
only virtual my students are
suffering they're breaking down i have
parents that are
on zooms with me crying about what's
going on with their
their kids at home for many children as
the pandemic has raged on their mental
health has continued to suffer
the cdc says between april and october
emergency departments saw a more than 30
percent
spike in visits from children 12 to 17
years old for mental health reasons
across the country millions of kids are
still attending school
only remotely do you feel the kids that
are learning virtually
their mental health is declining 100
percent sherry glassman is a school
psychologist in rocco's district where
there's a hybrid program
some students in person and others are
virtual
our virtual students are dealing with a
lot of isolation
a lot of screen burnout glassman credits
rocco's improvement with early
intervention
proactive parents and returning to
school in person
how many calls do you receive a day from
parents worried about their children
at least five to ten calls a day and
it's all about mental health issues
dr maria urovi is a pediatrician in new
jersey
she said the calls she gets are about
kids as young as kindergarten
through college what are the biggest
signs you should look for if you think
your child is
really struggling not to want to be
involved in activities not wanting to
eat just staying in the room
sleeping in a september survey more than
half of children
ages 11 to 17 reported they had thoughts
of suicide or self-harm
nearly half or every day in the previous
two weeks
they were also more likely than any
other age group to have moderate to
severe
symptoms of anxiety and depression what
should you do if you think your child is
going to harm themselves straight to the
hospital
and what should you do if you think your
child is depressed get help
get absolute health call yeah call a
psychologist call somebody get help for
them and for the family rocco told us
speaking publicly to
us about his mental health has also
helped
that definitely made me feel happy and
like a lot better that
i was making an impact on other people
it's not easy to talk about your mental
health do you realize that that was
a really brave thing you did yeah
why is it so important to keep this
conversation going
because it definitely normalizes these
feelings and it ends that stigma
of mental health issues i mean there
should be no stigma around it
people need to talk about these things
and know that other people are going
through the same things they are
one clinician at a mental health care
facility here in new jersey told me they
are
overwhelmed by the number of calls from
parents of struggling kids
as we face this mental health crisis
rocco school psychologist says
she hopes bringing kids back in person
is prioritized
tony all right meg thank you very much
bravo to rocco for speaking up yeah
officially what i was going to do we
like to hear that remember we all
reacted and thought that was so brave
he does he i know he's not going to want
to hear this but he's a very
good-looking little kid
[Laughter]
very good-looking little kid and so i
praise him and his mom for allowing them
to come
and talk so candidly yeah and i like the
fact that he's owning it saying yeah
he's glad that he did it because it will
help other kids
yeah it does get better it does get
better all right meg thank you very much